hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're yeah what straight
not the trailer we gonna watch a short
no I'm called retreat it's a horror
short film guys from the channel another
view this comes from a fairly new patron
who I gave an awkward shout out to a
while ago his name is low heat Banerjee
last time I saw it says his name I said
the height bernard j
he's actually been a follower channel
for like two and a half years this guy
big fan of psychological thrillers and
he's calling this a horse for a film so
this better be kind of scary at least
whatever you're 24 years old and you
live in canada that's probably nicest
horror film ever yeah we're watching
this because one of our top reward tiers
on patreon is whatever video you request
we must definitely cover so yeah patreon
we mainly do TV show reactions for many
of shows including weekly Q&A s is one
of our top reward tiers every once in a
while allows us to check out a short
film from an aspiring filmmaker who
follows our channels happy to do that
for you we will give you most negative
feedback in the world I am ready I'm
ready to prove that I do not kiss ass to
no one unless they're famous and more
successful than us the only way you're
gonna learn
to
[Music]
get the [ __ ] out of there man
okay that was back
[Music]
that was the Buchan reverse yeah
[Music]
interesting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
dude this sound design on this is
terrified Oh Wilson Fisk
Oh No
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] man interesting
post Christine
yeah surprising more effective than I
anticipated it was also just
structurally I just wasn't expecting
something quite as out there you know
always appreciative oh I like that
reverse effect that he was doing and
though yeah the way you talking about
the structure if going in reversed and
seeing him play out going and reversing
to play out when I'm doing this is like
really jarring POV with this like
unsettling and breathing and oh do with
headphones on that was genuinely scary
yeah you know some edges and stuff you
know like this is something I imagine
you probably made in a shoestring but
like it is effective like how unsettling
and strange it is I was genuinely taken
aback by that the only thing I liked
seemed off about it was the the ending
credits I would have to go back and like
pick it apart and feel like what is this
really about I mean I'm talking about
the actual credits oh the actual
credence oh you mean like being comic
books and comics ads and the different
colors the actual short film I thought
was for like a three-minute cool little
horror effect it was surprisingly well
executed man it's moody and yeah the
mood is really well done in I guess the
last thing I was actually expecting was
to get a little scared and I was
genuinely a little scared when I was
watching so I was like whoo this is
really intense I don't know how this
would play without headphones on yeah I
don't know if it would be as effective
but with headphones on those sound
effects were really friggin gnarly it
makes you feel for this guy because it's
like can you see what's going on there
and yeah and what state is he and
because so much of what we see of his is
is in Reverse and is very sort of
dreamlike and change and you also have
the playing with black and white versus
color and stuff right right right and
even when he gets is like head smashed
in who's like good your choice on the
sound effects there because you don't
see it I was kind of hoping we get one
shot where we would see it yeah like
with the brain popping out yeah or like
in the reverse effect
yeah oh yeah that would have been cool
to have that little visual there but I
understand you guys are you know making
this often nothing hey I guess I
half-expected the door to for it to end
on the door slamming in Reverse and that
being yeah yeah honestly way better
executed then I genuinely thought it
would be I was like I don't know about
this anyone who ever says like check out
my horror for I'm usually like okay
alright watch this I was like hey that
wasn't bad yeah definitely got stuff to
build on here right male like I think
like out the gate like you've got some
cool instincts and stuff like that yeah
specially as you're heading off to
school for for writing and productions
don't like you definitely got things you
can build upon and I'm curious to see
what you make after it's very apparent
that like you keep consistent and you
keep at your skill set that's made me
more curious to see like what's up your
sleeve in terms of storytelling because
I get this is like an effective mood
piece kind of an experimental piece and
in terms of structure I'm Q really
curious like well how would you handle
character now how would you handle like
a 10 minute piece as opposed to a three
minute piece so you had my attention
yeah my curiosity is that wasn't reverse
so that yeah yeah gotta walk before you
can crawl which is an actual like flub
that they just went with because it just
worked too well yeah okay yeah it also
made me really curious as to what this
thing is that's doing this to this poor
poor guy it seemed like yeah I mean
you're locked into its perspective and
it yes and its head making weird noises
boom what the hell was you feel like
you're in its head because you know
you're breathing really heavy nerves
kind of like staring all around and I
think that's what was weirdly effective
about it cuz when you're watching it
from his perspective it's in Reverse and
then when you're watching in it not in
Reverse you're watching it from the
demons perspective which I thought was
such a weird structure but it's it works
so well yeah I'm like it's one of those
things where I'm not entirely sure what
to make of all this but each choice I
did find at least like gripping in a way
interesting you know what's going on
here I think your credits ed story and
screenplay by two people so it's making
me wonder - do you guys have like a
bigger
thing in mind the two of you working on
just this one outline we've got a
commentary track for ya like some
special features maybe you know Steve
deleted scenes or whatever maybe like a
shooting script just to get a better
sense for you know the undercurrent I
guess I'm surprised because I this made
me a lot more curious into your mind and
yet the other stuff is around this as
well so yeah good work dude thank you
for making this and Senator away dude I
always appreciate a horror short that
comes out surreal instead of just like a
setup and a punch line yeah when we go
to Canada man we're gonna make something
scary together yeah cuz we make core
comedies once in a while
thanks for watching and please go give
another view to low heat channel called
another view go give some views to
another view you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and hey check us on
patreon TV show reactions q and A's
would love to have you come to Toronto
check today